are you kidding me
are you kidding me alvin
comedian gabriel iglesias has mastered
the art of making people laugh
but what i want to know is can the guy
hold his own flipping patties
we're gonna find out as i mold fluffy
into the ultimate burger warrior and
teach him how to cook some mind-blowing
recipes
in the company of his vintage car
collection and for all his hard work i'm
going to surprise him with a special
tailor-made burger
in his honor you don't want to miss this
fluffy what's up i'm chilling dude i'm
waiting i i
i you know all of a sudden the camera's
rolling and there's food in front of me
and it's not prepared and that's that's
sad
i'm used to pulling up the
drive-throughs and then i i placed my
order and then magically it appears
we're bringing it today we're bringing
it today we're gonna be cooking some
burgers you know i've
cooked all over the place and i've never
cooked
in front of a fleet of beautiful vw
vintage
buses before i've done coachella i've
done award shows
but this is a first i could say i was
your first at something right
i'm popping your volkswagen cherry let's
do this man exactly
you've got a lot going on mr iglesias
amazing show and then you have something
new unleashed on nickelodeon yes uh
unleashed is a uh imagine america's got
talent but with animals
okay so in case anybody's wondering
whether there's like dogs roaming around
you'll see them
you're like is that like a straight dog
they're mine
they're mine they're just are they gonna
be on the show uh actually yes they are
on the show
fluffy stays busy i mean i'm a meat
cheese bun guy
is that what you're about you know what
uh if this was a religion this is
this would definitely be my uh my thing
uh i think life is much better when
you're eating a burger
if you're like to rate your burger
skills from one to ten what do you think
it would be
it's been so long i'd probably give
myself a solid four right now a four
we'll take that four today hopefully the
goal is to take it up to at least a five
okay if not we'll go for a 10. you'd be
a little bit under promise
let's under promise over deliver are we
going to do this because man i'm getting
nancy
you're a west coast guy i'm a west coast
guy so we got to make a west coast
burger right
all right so tell me what i'm doing got
sesame seed bun we'll just throw this on
there
that is one of the most impressive uh
like
what would you even call this dude read
it look what it's called hell's
hand hell's handle pills that's serious
business
that's that's when you know when you
hear the sizzle you know you're on the
right track
we grab our burger balls and we throw
them onto the griddle all right so i'm
grabbing a burger ball
yeah grab them both you want me to grab
both of my burger balls
for the record yes i do have a kid show
cool and then we grab your hell's handle
grab my hell's handle and then your
dowel here this is a chiseler's dial
okay
and you basically just grab it and smash
just like this
hey this looks like this thing from the
80s where the iron sheik used to work
out with these
drums i don't know some old school guys
are watching this like remember he'd
work out with these
i'm old sorry so i'm going to smush this
down yeah smush them up
what this is doing is you're basically
getting contact
sure he could have his dogs on the show
what's the worst that could happen
i think i have uh smashed these burgers
impressively and evenly
beautiful notice we haven't seasoned it
yet a little bit of a special powder
right here i don't know if you can tell
let's see the magical powder
hmm garlic powdered ranch dressing
oh wow okay sprinkle a little that magic
powder over the top yeah perfect and
then we'll hit it with black pepper
after that
while this is cooking let's mix our
secret sauce mayonnaise ketchup
jalapenos ah okay yes
fluffy sauce this is the hard part we're
gonna try to scrape this
off the griddle
[Music]
and okay i just want to go on record and
say that i've
successfully flipped two patties they
look
very presentable and i know that the
camera's only on me
you don't have a camera directly on this
food but you should because that's how
good it is
oh correction you can yeah see that see
that [ __ ] right there
you see that
we got here a little bit of chipotle
infused
olive oil just brush some chili oil on
top of those those patties give the
burger a bath
yeah kind of like my oats to in and out
right they kind of put mustard on it and
they i love it with chopped chilies
so we're just gonna throw some spice
into it and then we're just gonna throw
the cheese on top then we'll put some of
that secret sauce on both
top and bottom all right so
the impressive stacking oh look at that
that's looking
dude look at that that's food stylist
level let's give them a seven now let's
see
we're raising you to a seven right i
think my burger game is up to a seven
and like the ultra west coast
move just wrap it like a baby just like
this
wrap it like a baby all right good moon
little burger
there's a west coast burger right here
you know what that's not bad i'm all
about this
crispiness creaminess bunniness all of
that is
all of that is in here all of that is in
here
super good west coast till i die
burger number two is something that i
got inspired because i watched you on
tacos con todo
and you said that you love quesadillas
when people ask me what is your favorite
food your favorite thing to eat in life
yeah cheese quesadilla yes and so you've
been monitoring my food activity oh yeah
okay i see how it is oh yeah man i was
like
let's do the best of both worlds let's
make a molita
basically yeah it's a burger with
tortillas exactly
exactly and by definition a burger is
just supposed to be
minced and meat in a bun right and uh i
guess flour is
flour tortillas you know it's just a
different form of bun quick glance we
have
some of our typical accoutrement
sour cream guac some cheese so
i got these tortilla presses right here
this is a legit
tortilla press right here so what i
wanted to do since we already have
tortillas
made i wanted to throw the burger patty
in there
and smash it you're all about the burger
patty and i i for one am not going to
argue with you
here we go let's smash her up let's uh
the show's all about smashing stuff i
love it
oh it came out the sides dude check that
out oh yeah it is coming out the side
that's cool i'm gonna put the burger
patty smackdown right here
huh you like how you're wrestling with a
burger patty smackdown
rip it off a little bit of salt it's
basically a
there you go bam a little bit of a solid
seasoning
i feel like this one's going to be a
little bit more challenging on the flip
this is the burger you're going to have
to earn your stripes
let's go i i know you can do it
you almost lost it there bro but nice
recovery
it started to fold but you know what
nice recovery
still one piece baby can we play that
back in slow motion
what i like to do when i make
quesadillas i like to get a little bit
of this chili oil
and brush it onto the tortilla okay i'm
all about getting some oil on a tortilla
here
and by the way anybody who makes a
quesadilla dry like if you do like if
you
fire up get a komal going and you don't
put anything on the tortilla you're
you're so
you're just robbing yourself of a yeah
you're an amazing flavor
mine is hot we'll set it aside
and then we'll grab our tortilla and
then
smackdown oil upside down boom
spread it all on top top base say hello
to cheese bake
cheese bae you got real good coverage on
that actually
now since we kept the burger on the spat
we'll just throw it
right back on yeah can i just say i am
living
a childhood fantasy right now because uh
this is where i'd be getting yelled at
then we'll get our top bun aka
the other tortilla get that contact make
sure that cheese sticks
brush some more this chili oil ready all
right i'm gonna try
this here here we go we'll do something
that's never been done let's go let's do
a look away
oh nice but look at that color that we
got on there
that's all flavor right there we're
gonna kick it up a notch seriously how's
it gonna get better than this because
uh yeah i put more cheese
all right just to increase the level of
difficulty now
i got this torch bam
oh wow wow
i just tried to blow torch a fly is that
wrong
so now we get that nice cheese brulee
i've i've never used a blowtorch before
this is cool yeah right
you want to put on some sour cream on
the side now when it comes to
guacamole guacamole guac i got some guac
it's really good guac
it's free at chipotle because i know
reuben and he's such a sweetheart and so
he gave me some
some free guac but before we taste this
we have these three mind-blowing hot
sauces
from hot ones i'm gonna let you pick the
poison
this isn't this isn't hot one so i'm not
gonna force it on you
you know what whatever you do i'll do
this brings back some memories
ah are we doing it we're doing it so we
got here
the last dab apollo hot sauce so
uh oh dude did that just like like pop
open
yeah sour cream just a little bit okay
that i already think is too much
there's definitely some hot sauce on
this yeah for all the trolls out there
hi i'm eating
what's up oh wow
memory lane that's hot respect to that
last dab
it definitely changed up the game oh wow
i sound different now
i'm going to give you a high 8.75 on
this one 8.75 baby
fluffy you did a great job you passed
the test
now i just want you to relax take it
easy i've gloved up i've mashed up and
now it's time for me
to make you something that you love
making it safe
yeah so it's gonna be off the top
turnbuckle slam
of a burger it's gonna be inspired by
our man steve austin
some cold stone cold don't call big
texas dude
so i wanted to make a texas style patty
mill
just for you inspired by everything that
you love i see something very special on
that plate right there
got that smoked beef rib texas style
salt and pepper
used a little bit of oak on that and i
got this dry aged patty right here
so we're making a chili cheese
patty milk with a short rib stuffed
inside it
clearly my friends at the make-a-wish
foundation got my message and uh
come true right now in texas they use
heavy
coarse black pepper all this talk about
texas why do you like stone cold so much
because i'm a huge fan of professional
wrestling i've been a big fan my whole
life and
stone cold was just one of those guys
that man i don't know i just i clicked
with him he was he was so cool
and i've had the pleasure of hanging out
with him and he's the same dude which is
funny
really yeah yeah he does it's the same
he's the same guy you have to go texas
toast right
we have to go texas toast so yeah you
can start to smell the pepper
the fat is slowly melting it's gonna
create that nice sear
i'm gonna go throw some cheese on it i
was wondering when you were gonna add
the magic
we're gonna top it with a little bit of
chili i feel like i'm watching someone
paint a picasso
wow lit it uh this is the part where i
grab my phone cause i gotta take a
picture of this
for the gram check that out i'm gonna
pull the bone out
you're gonna take this entire thing and
dip it into the queso
whole my bam god
all right he pulled a bone out of my
sandwich
and now i have to dip it in cheese my
texas
burger you can name it you know what uh
in honor of a stone cold steve austin i
think we definitely need to
name this the bottom line
because it doesn't get better than that
because stone cold said so there you go
beef rib patty chili coconut
queso let's go i need four hands i feel
like i gotta beat it
you know there's oh my god normally i
would
i would front dip but there's no way i
can front dip then flip back for me to
eat this so i'm gonna have to
pull a first ever reverse dip
whoa and then uh
take it backwards to the face oh my god
are you kidding me are you kidding me
boom i think i nailed it yeah this is
the last thing i
ever eat i can die a happy man
thanks for being on the show thank you i
appreciate it i've been wanting to do
this for a really
long time i didn't know that i've been
wanting to do this for a long time until
it happened
i am all about it tomorrow when this is
leaving uh you know the fluffy palace
i'm gonna be screaming your name i'm
gonna be sitting there remembering
it could be good it could be bad
[Music]
what's up everybody thank you for
watching the burger show make sure you
hit that like button
make sure you smash that subscribe
button hit that notification bell
if not for me for the burgers thank you